let's go to the phone 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50
we're going to start with our first
caller from the 3 1 2 area code caller
what's your name and where you're
calling from hey how are you doing David
this is Jose from Chicago awesome what's
on your mind today so um I kind of
wanted to talk about the whole Russia
and Trump thing real quick I'm I'm kind
of wondering if if this whole trying to
impeach Trump thing would even be a good
good thing at all
um the way I mean and I read an article
earlier today saying the Trump
impeachment might not be the panacea
that some progressives think it would be
because number one it would it could end
with Mike Pence being President of the
United States number two it might fail
because again an impeachment is sort of
an indictment and you still have to then
go through the impeachment proceedings
to determine whether the president has
actually done what you are accusing the
president of having done and it might
not work and if it doesn't work in
removing Trump that would be just a
major backfire and loss of credibility
which would probably help Republicans in
2018 and 2020 I think there's a lot to
that I mean why are you concerned that
it might not be that great of an idea I
mean you just the idea of having someone
who has Trump's ideas but it's just more
calculated is a lot scarier to me than
some then Trump himself if you know what
I mean I agree I mean the thing is so
Pat Mike Pence would be much more
effective he doesn't really have Trump's
ideas he has other ideas which are
horrifying I mean we're talking about a
real right-wing ideologue in Mike Pence
they're obviously similar in some ways
though I mean the thing is now that
because there's scandals day-to-day
I mean his agenda kind of gets pushed by
the wayside I mean we're not really
talking about tax reform in health care
at this point yeah that's kind of one of
the benefits but you know if you have
Mike Pence in there I think the benefit
is that we we know that we're not going
to end up destroying the planet from
nuclear weapon I was thinking about that
which is are we really going that nobody
talking about a healthcare vote in the
Senate right now right so that that's
suspended the tax plan the who the
one-page bullet-point tax plan that
trump put out nobody's talking about
that because every day is a new scandal
that is an argument for keeping Trump in
but the thing is won't people eventually
become desensitized to the scandals I
wonder I don't know in any case a very
very good question appreciate the call
always great to hear from Chicago hope
to talk to you again soon all right
thanks all right thanks so much